a very different scene down under the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex better known
as Prince Harry and Megan Markel are
wrapping up their first week of a four
nation overseas tour the first stop is
of course Australia where Harry has just
opened the fourth Invictus games
Jonathan Vigliotti takes us on the Royal
Tour Down Under
Prince Harry officially kicked off his
Invictus games outside Sydney's iconic
Opera House in the hours leading up to
the ceremony Kensington Palace tweeted
this photo of the Prince practising for
an audience of one his wife Megan
Harry created the week-long competition
in 2014 to help injured veterans earlier
the couple attended a ceremony to unveil
a world war one Memorial today marks day
5 of a whirlwind 16 day Commonwealth
tour of Australia Fiji Tonga and New
Zealand and the couple has been welcomed
with open arms from Sydney where the
crowds lined up to congratulate them on
the news they're expecting a baby - the
farming community of dubbo where their
future parenting skills were put to the
test the tour has also become a platform
for the couple to use their celebrity to
shine a light on causes they care about
nowhere was that more on display than
when they sat barefoot in the sand with
a surf group that gathers weekly to
discuss their personal struggles this is
meant to be one of the more intimate
moments of the trip so far the royal
couple choosing Bondi Beach as the
backdrop to discuss mental health a
topic important to both of them
their royal rock stars and Megan who's
on her first overseas tour is doing
exceptionally well says royal
correspondent Roy Anika I think Harry
Megan are definitely bringing a new
image which we've seen this morning
barefoot chic on the beach surfing
mental health very relaxed I mean this
is I suppose the future of bits of the
monarchy and that's the sort of future
freshness that Harry i'ma gonna bring
into the firm this royal family is
growing in more ways than one for CBS
this morning Saturday Jonathan Vigliotti
Sydney Australia